depuis la fermeture des bars des
restaurants le 30 octobre dernier les
grossistes et distributeurs de boissons
boivent le bouillon leur stock de soda
ou d'alcool ne trouvent plus preneur et
certaines dates de consommation arrivent
à échéance
amboise fayette boissons a donc décidé
d'ouvrir son entrepôt aux particuliers
pour faire un peu de vide
plus d'explications dans ce reportage de
paul boyer des milliers de caisses de
sodas de jus de fruits d'alcool n'ont
pas bougé depuis presque six mois dans
les entrepôts fayette
les stocks sont bientôt arriver à la
date limite
fermée depuis fin octobre l'entreprise
amboisienne est contraint de se séparer
d'une bonne partie de ces boissons
on ne peut pas tourner on l'a tous nos
chauffeurs sont à l'arrêt les camions
sont rangés voilà on les voit car et on
est obligé au bout d'un moment de le
procédé par à déstockage procéder par
quelque chose parce que quand tout va
rouvrir nos clients on va remettre
d'eilat qui sont dans dans les créneaux
et pouvoir avoir du recul sur la saison
qui va arriver sur l'année écoulée
l'établissement a perdu plus de 2
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
parmi les 17 salariés que compte
l'entreprise
presque la totalité sont encore en
chômage partiel sur notre exercice
comptable on a travaillé que cinq mois
sur 12 donc je peux vous comprendrez
assez aisément que on a été fortement
impactée sur notre chiffre d'affaires
pour le gérant les prêts garantis par
l'état et les aides de leur fournisseur
leur ont permis de tenir le coup il
envisage une réouverture pour fin avril
pour cela il faut se séparer les stocks
bientôt arriver à date de péremption
on a anticipé des choses on a d'ailleurs
prévu samedi une petite vente
exceptionnelle de produits qui sont
malheureusement plus d'actualité des
vins qui ont des millésimes trop vieux
des produits qui ont des dates de vie
qui vont s'arrêter
une braderie exceptionnelle aura lieu ce
samedi à amboise de 8h30 à 12h30
d'ici là le groupe fayette espère
pouvoir rapidement reprendre ses
activités